[Musica]
visto che il tema è il fuoco vi
chiederei Prima di tutto Chi ha un
lavoro qui dentro
e vorrebbe vedere
Ecco Vabbè io vi parlerò di un tema
super delicato e dovrò ottenere un certo
ritmo Spero che mi perdonerete per ritmo
che terrò perché l'idea del Ted è dare
degli spunti e io ho cercato di fare il
mio meglio per lasciare qualcosa che
possa essere utile non ho nessuna
velleità di convincere le persone però
visto che uno dei temi che da tanto
tempo c'è di approfondire è quello dei
conflitti in azienda magari Voi vivete
in posti in cui non si litiga mai non si
confligge mai si va sempre d'accordo
e vedo che non è così Quindi entro
subito nell'argomento il tema che che vi
porto è visto che si parla di fuoco
navigare il fuoco e quindi vedete dei
Principi per ottenere il meglio da nei
conflitti sul lavoro Quando dico la
parola conflitti chiamate la litigio
chiamate la discussione che amate il
confronto chiamato l'attrito chiamatelo
Come volete sostanzialmente persone due
o più che non hanno la stessa idea su
qualcosa questo è il concetto
fondamentale noi
non amiamo i conflitti per noi in
compenso amiamo molto i conflitti degli
altri e cioè l'interesse mediatico di
questo conflitto per esempio mi fa
pensare davvero che siamo così siamo
siamo molto particolari Se tu dici Ma tu
ami discutere con gli altri avere delle
diatribe così mica tanto ma di Shakira
so tutto e quindi e quindi questa cosa è
già particolare perché ci porta in un
campo che insomma è ambiguo o un divago
questi sono alcuni dati non vite dirò
perché nelle raccomandazioni dei Ted c'è
sempre scritto Non mettete degli elenchi
puntati Io mi sono permesso di rompere
una regola alla fine perché ci tenevo
davvero non tanto a venire qui a fare il
sapiente cose che non sono quanto
piuttosto lasciare quei punti che io ho
trovato molto utili per cavarsela un po'
meglio nei conflitti lavorativi quindi
le ultime tre slide Anzi sì le ultime
tre slide mettiamola così sono degli
elenchi puntati che io spero vi saranno
utili
l'unico altro elenco puntato è questo
che vedete no sostanzialmente meno della
metà di lavoratori viene formato in tema
di gestione dei conflitti e quelle altre
che vedete intorno sono tutte quante che
vi lascio leggere da soli senza
diventare didascalico sono tutti quanti
come dire frutti e conseguenze della
conflittualità in azienda come vedete il
tema è delicato nel senso ha molti
conseguenze negative ce n'è una che
riguarda le aziende soprattutto che però
è come dire contro intuitiva Questa
yandevic è una psicologa è una Valente
psicologa canadese sottolinea che quando
non si affrontano le tematiche
conflittuali all'interno della
professione del lavoro perché di questo
Poi io mi intendo e solo di questo e si
forma un debito da conflitto Ecco il
debito da conflitto Tenete conto che sia
una specie di grande debito che si crea
in qualsiasi organizzazione questo caso
economica non solo quando le persone
dovrebbero dirsi delle cose dovrebbero
trovare delle soluzioni dovrebbero
tirare fuori qualche novità creativa e
invece preferisco per il quieto vivere
evitarlo Quindi c'è un punto
interessante quando non si litiga
aggiungo bene quando non si confligge
aggiungo bene
qualcuno paga
vi ho lasciato uno spunto che potrebbe
essere interessante perché ama il cinema
ma anche perché non lo ama c'è un
bellissimo film del 57
la regista Sidney lume in cui si
intitola twelve Hungry Man se vi
capitano andate a vederlo trovate anche
su YouTube Comunque ve la faccio breve
si tratta di un caso giudiziario in cui
un ragazzo minorenne viene accusato di
aver ucciso il padre è una famiglia che
è cresciuta nella povertà e ci sono 12
giurati uno degli giurati a Henry Fonda
che si trovano fin dall'inizio quasi a
parte uno tutti d'accordo del dire che
questo ragazzo è colpevole sulla base di
indizi quindi non di proprio oggettive
perché nessuno esattamente ha visto le
cose Beh ve la faccio breve perché poi
vi dirò come va a finire questo però è
giurato numero 10 in tutto il film è
giurato non vengono quasi mai chiamati
con loro nome vengono chiamati giurato
uno due tre quattro cinque il giurato 10
dice ho vissuto in mezzo a loro per
tutta la vita gente povera non puoi
credere una parola di quello che dicono
lo sai Voglio dire Quelli sono elementi
bugiardi ricordatevelo perché lo tirerò
fuori alla fine e cercherò di darvi
questa suggestione perché aiuta molto a
capire dove voglio andare a parare Beh
però prima dicevo che il debito da
conflitto è un problema per le aziende
ma il problema per gli individui per me
per te per te per voi per tutti quanti
noi qual è Immagino che voi abbiate già
fatto amicizia molti di voi molti di noi
hanno già fatto amicizia con un tema che
è la disintermediazione Quindi tutti
quei casi in cui qualcosa viene a vedere
se tu Aggiungi ancora valore al tuo
lavoro e dice visto che non ne aggiungi
abbastanza ti tiro via dall'anello come
anello dalla catena di fornitura Il che
vuol dire che tu per esempio perdi il
lavoro quella frase è una parte il tuo
margine la mia opportunità è forse del
campione della disintermediazione che è
Jeff bezos che è uno che ha fondato una
piattaforma che tendenzialmente chiede a
tutti che ne so i commercianti Ma voi
esattamente che valore apportate
spostate merci da un posto all'altro
faccio io e questo fa scomparire enormi
enormi enormi fette del per come lo
conoscevamo ne nasceranno altre però per
il momento le fa scomparire questa cosa
si chiama irrilevanza si potrebbe stare
qui veramente una giornata a parlana ed
è molto interessante ed è forse il
grande vero problema per chi vorrebbe
avere un lavoro domani io sono rilevante
oppure no ecco facciamo così da una
parte per rimanere rilevanti si tratta
di aggiungere valore intelligenza
artificiale tecnologie tentano di
sostituire l'uomo Cosa rimane rimane la
richiesta di creatività qual è il
problema è che la creatività è quasi
sempre frutto di tensioni attriti e
conflitti quasi mai la creatività parlo
da un punto di vista produttivo
organizzativo economico è frutto del
genio di un singolo che fa tutto ma è
data dalla discussione anche animata e
anche di attrito fra le persone quindi
quindi noi abbiamo un problema ed è che
non siamo particolarmente bravi a
gestire i conflitti nemmeno da frontali
e ci troviamo in un periodo storico in
cui essere capaci di gestire in maniera
alfabetizzata i conflitti potrebbe
essere l'unico escamotage possiamo avere
un futuro professionale la cosa è
peggiorata da questa cosa che vedete che
sono le Eco Chambers e le Filter Bubbles
qualcuno ne avrà sentito parlare
sostanzialmente se andate a vedere il
feed del vostro dei vostri Social
vedrete che noi voi tutti quanti noi
frequentiamo e vediamo mondi che ci
confermano continuamente e che ci dicono
che abbiamo ragione e che abbiamo più
ragione e che ci dicono che gli altri
hanno torto tanto torto Tutto il torto
quindi il giusto è sbagliato e questi
meccanismi algoritmici frutto di social
che hanno la necessità di vendere cose
quindi di confermarti nelle tue scelte
creano un problema creano polarizzazione
creano incapacità di trovare soluzioni
immediate o cooperative e conflitti come
dire la situazione è peggiore della
analfabetizzazione circa i conflitti è
montata dal fatto e lo vedete anche
nella società civile che noi pensiamo
che tutti gli altri siano nel torto E
che tutti noi siamo nel giusto potrei
portarvi molti esempi
Questo vuol dire che quando però tu
prendi gli aspetti sociali che sui
social sono molto chiari in termini di
polarizzazione che sono aspetti sociali
crediamo in questa cosa non crediamo in
questa cosa è giusta questa cosa che non
è giusta questa cosa e poi li
Trasformiamo e li trasportiamo in campo
professionale Dove lavoriamo e quindi
abbiamo lo stesso atteggiamento
polarizzante e giudicatoio e di opinione
che abbiamo nei social Tu sei scemo no
sei scemo tu no sono scemo eh quando
questa pozione viene portata in campo
aziendale tutti i Privi dell'unica arma
che hai per rimanere lì davanti che è la
creatività e la capacità di affrontare
conflitti e quindi portiamo in campo
professionale fuga attacco e fingersi
morti ma anche fingersi morti però di
più fuga o attacco Quindi qual è il tema
dove voglio andare a parare negli ultimi
minuti è questo Cioè necessità di una
alfabetizzazione per me e per tanti di
noi per curare questa miopia cognitiva
Nel senso che da una parte noi abbiamo
la necessità professionale di essere
innovativi e di creare dall'altra parte
non vogliamo farlo e polarizziamo
pensando di avere tutte le ragioni
la padronanza del conflitto che io ho
scritto in questo modo è la capacità di
orientarsi in un conflitto costruttivo è
esattamente il punto e anche l'idea che
io vi volevo proporre oggi vi volevo
suggerire ma mi volevo suggerire perché
io stesso da un po' di anni che ci
dedico tempo comprendo che è un cammino
ed è un processo che però necessita
quantomeno di aver compreso il perché lo
dovrei fare il mio mentore che si chiama
Daniele Novara psicopedagogista molto
famoso Immagino che molti di voi lo
conoscano a questa bella frase dice
Attenzione che violento e chi non sa
come litigare bene è questo è un po' un
tema non è violento Chi litiga e
violento chi non sa litigare la violenza
è esattamente la risposta quando uno o
una persona non è alfabetizzata e quindi
deve passare le forme più estreme i
principi del Navigante nel fuoco sono
questi io ve li ho messi giù e in questo
caso era quella rottura dello schema di
Ted che mi sono permesso di fare anche
per iniziare questa giornata perché
avrete tantissimi tantissimi colleghi e
colleghe che vi intratterranno su tanti
tanti temi e capisco che questo sia un
tema particolarmente difficoltoso da
affrontare però vedete cose come
ascoltare rispettosamente l'idea degli
altri essere capaci di chiarire le
posizioni delle persone in maniera da
comprendere esattamente dove
differiscono riparafrasare ciò che non è
chiaro vedere quali sono i punti di
accordi disaccordo essere critici verso
le persone e non verso le idee e quindi
separare il valore personale dall'idea
quindi non non continuare a mischiare la
persona con ciò che dice e poi
obiettivo come tentare di prendere la
decisione migliore possibile quella
razionale è quella più importante è
quella vera essere un sostenitore
dell'accesso delle informazioni per
tutti in maniera che tutti possano
Portare la loro apporto di creatività
dare molta razionalità e Fuggire da lì
Io credo che io penso che essere
continuamente magistrati sacerdoti Guru
Santoni in cui la tua verità è la
migliore per definizione e poi provare a
mettersi nei panni degli altri ecco sono
tutti quanti spunti che io ho messo giù
poi se vi sarà necessario Immagino che
il materiale sarà a disposizione e
comunque a disposizione anche da me e
l'ho riassunto in questa ultima regola
d'oro del conflitto no agire come gli
avversari Scusate agire con gli
avversari Come vorrei che agissero con
me Ecco questi erano gli spunti che nei
12 minuti che avevo a disposizione mi
sarebbe piaciuto darvi e credo ci siamo
arrivati sono cose pratiche che si
possono mettere in atto velocemente e
credo che avranno un grande impatto vi
lascio con la chiusura della storia che
avevo raccontato prima e vi invito
davvero a guardare questo bel film in
bianco e nero Ecco alla fine di questa
di questo processo in cui piano piano i
giurati cominciano a parlare con loro e
passano dall'essere tutti quanti
praticamente tutti A parte uno convinti
da colpevolezza di questo ragazzo quale
pregiudiziali di cui vi ho parlato prima
un po' alla volta ragionando applicando
tutti quei quegli spunti che avete visto
prima arrivano alla convinzione che il
ragazzo sia innocente e allora è proprio
una rifonda il giurato il numero 8 Henry
Fonda che dice con una frase che è
rimasta molto celebre in questo in
questo film dice ogni volta che ci
caschi dentro i pregiudizio oscura
sempre la verità e con questo Io vi
saluto e vi ringrazio
[Applauso]